by the way haley steinfeld is here
everybody
sorry i went right in you've turned me
into a giddy girl i can't help it
um i want to thank you for inspiring me
to pick up this collected poem of emily
dixon
dickinson i saw season one and by the
way david gordon green the director who
directed the premier in the first
episode is one of my favorite directors
and i just loved the tone of it and now
season two i've been watching that it's
incredible
um you have been a huge fan of emily
dickinson before the show is this right
yeah so i came across emily's work in
in school uh but i hadn't i've never
spent as much time as i have with her
because of this show and i am equally as
thankful to this show for
sort of reintroducing me to her and her
story and her poetry
um because it is so incredible and i
have really felt
so impacted by her work and her words um
i almost wish i came across it sooner uh
at least to this
degree um but i guess that's why we have
the show now and i am
so excited about it and grateful that we
have a season two out
um and very excited for people to see it
she must be a very emotional person
to portray and embody did that take over
in effect
absolutely one thing about emily's
poetry that you will find very quickly
she talks about everything
from death to
demons and light nature
trees butterflies and everything in
between and it is it is emotional
exactly what you said it it's
uh it takes you to dark darker places
and places you don't necessarily want to
spend a lot of time in
um but what's so wonderful about this
show is it touches on that and in the
same moment or in the next moment you're
laughing and there
it's there's humor behind it that makes
it feel
um you know as light as it can dark
sometimes it's got really everything in
it
and it's all driven by her poetry it's
incredibly delightful yet full of depth
and i know it won a peabody award
which is just
thank you i know it's really such an
honor i mean to
to be making a story about a woman who
spent the majority of her life
um you know unseen
at least she felt unseen and
misunderstood
and beyond that no one even knew her
work until after she died
um and to be making a show about
that and having the opportunity in my
position to be an actor that has a
platform and has a voice um it's made me
realize how grateful i am and
and you know to the peabody awards so
incredibly grateful that they continue
to shine a light on stories that
mean something and and this is a show
that is about not putting people in a
box and
seeing and being seen and being accepted
for who you are
and um we can never have enough of those
and so i'm i'm
incredibly honored that we were given
that um that reward
and is it true i know so wonderful i
i had to talk about that and is it true
also that each
episode is based on a poem
yes yes and it's fun often times i will
associate my favorite poem with
my favorite episode and it changes all
the time i find um
but elena smith our writer and creator
is
a genius and uh my emily dickinson
encyclopedia as i like to call her
and knows anything and everything there
is to know about her and she has taken
what we do know about her life
uh and the rest is us interpreting her
crazy mind and and again using her
poetry and we get the results of a
really
fun show well i loved hearing that
detail
while watching it and knowing that piece
of information because it's a very
clever structure
[Music]